so for the first time ever Nikko and
myself are here at nab in Las Vegas what
does that I beat it is the National
Association of Broadcasters and
basically this is the biggest filmmaking
convention in the entire world everyone
is here red cameras here canons here
black magics here literally everyone to
see are showing off all the cool new
tech and gear that they have filmmakers
so we're gonna head in and we're gonna
check it out and show you guys what is
in store it's like III but for stuff
that's actually useful not video games
filmmaking tools all right let's do this
this is a spherical GoPro rig we're
basically all the GoPros are aligned and
then all the images are then brought
back together and stitched into a
spherical map as you can see they have
it hooked up to an oculus rift so you
can get inside that sphere of GoPros and
get a perfect panorama of the area
you're in where we shot our Superman
video we are actually considering trying
to create a rig like this to give us the
most ultimate wide field of view to look
around in while flying around so now
that we know about it they we have to
save this for the next one
this is just like a video game we get to
upgrade your weapons with more
experience points I just upgraded to the
massive railgun
penis french fries
you want you to crazy assume lens in the
world
everything's that I don't know but he's
really far away
I
oh sweet filter time automatic and more
effective
crazy
it's probably one of the coolest things
in the show floor at the end of Ruth
here they have a wireless sensor based
focused polling system where they actor
a subject where's little sensor and
there's these little boxes that you said
that create a magnetic field and the
sensor can tell where it is based on
this magnetic field therefore the camera
knows where your subject is and it will
automatically pull focus to wherever you
want to hold so like basically you can
strap something on somebody haven't run
around the lens will go crazy focusing
on them all without you having to even
touch things because we live in the year
2014 and it's future
lots of people are here including some
of our favorite guys the GoPro guys are
here
we're actually speaking on stage about
our Superman video they invited us here
to actually talk about the Superman
video how we made it how we use GoPros
and all that stuff so it hasn't happened
yet but I'm looking forward to seeing
all the people who show up and are
interested in that video so we're gonna
check out some of the cool cameras here
Oh
so here we are at the red booth a lot of
you guys have a shoot a ton of our stuff
on the red some of you might not know is
that we actually upgraded to an epic
this ha winter and now we can shoot
stuff is slow-motion we can shoot
something 5k we're really looking
forward to the Dragon sensor because
imagine all the flexibility we have with
the red files taken with to the new
level like a better low-light a higher
resolution to be sweet anyways that
great sign out yet we're waiting we get
it finally check out also they don't
have wireless control so you can
actually control the camera from your
iPad so imagine pulling focus with your
iPhone on the camera it's pretty cool
stuff so even though I haven't used the
Blackmagic cameras myself yet it's
really interesting climbing by their
booth because the camera design is
honestly one of my favorites because
it's just a screen with a lens mount in
the front and so you're basically just
maximizing the viewing area you can
watch everything and it's a really small
light package they actually have a new
one this year with an even bigger screen
it's a studio version of their camera
and it's really nuts to watch footage on
the the Blackmagic pocket camera is
probably one of the cameras I kind of
want to use more than anything else
because of the fact that its size is
perfect for drone work and it's right
now the only camera that can shoot in
RAW at that size with that quality one
of our favorite pieces of software is
DaVinci Resolve you probably heard us
talk about it and when we talked about
color grading and that kind of stuff
there's a lite version that's free which
is nuts because it's such a powerful
program is basically be key to making
your footage look good they actually
announced the Cameo version
Levin this summer looking forward to
that has some cool automatic color
profiling options ways to if basically
shoot a color chart you can match it
between cameras that's all really neat
anyways you guys should definitely
download the software if you haven't yet
because it's a great tool to have in
your arsenal it's hard to beat the price
to zero dollars so a lot of you probably
heard about stabilizing Gimbels movie
and particularly being one of the
biggest ones out there however this year
they're all over the show floor but I
think movi still has probably the best
rig right now as indicated by the fact
they have one mounted on an electric
dirtbike or one mounted on a
remote-control car so your move
everybody else but you wish your keys